en fait ce qui s'est passé sincèrement
avec sacha c'est ce que vous me demandez
ce qui s'est passé avec ses achats c'est
que on s'est engueulé donc on a eu
beaucoup danglade vu que c'était un
amour très rapide et très passionnel
beaucoup d'engueulades moi je comprenais
pas certaines de ses actions parce que
bon feeling il mène un train de vie qui
ne me plaît pas et donc à ce moment-là
je quitte chez lui donc en fait vous
vous appuyez vous mener un train de vie
qui lui plaît pas et vous vous dites
qu'il mène un train de vie qui lui plaît
pas oui en fait tous les deux vous menez
en train de
nous je ne sais pas de quoi ils parlent
en tout cas moi son train de vie c'est
son train de vie de quoi sont rendus de
drogués voilà simplement on a parlé en
fait dans la vidéo de bastos et ça ne me
plaisait pas c'est pour ça que je
n'aimais pas ses amis et que j'essayais
de communes travaillait pas ni rien
j'essayais de faire en sorte qu'ils
mènent un train de vie un peu plus un
semblant donc ce qui s'est passé avec
sacha c'est que il m'envoie un message
et puis il me dit bien récupérer des
affaires donc je lui dis comme
j'habitais chez lui eh bien il faut que
je vienne faire mes affaires parce
qu'elles sont un peu partout il ne
refuse donc j'ai tous les messages c'est
juste que sacha beaucoup plus d'audience
que moi sur internet et sur les réseaux
il me demande de venir chercher des sacs
lui-même a fait une fois que je vois
dans les sacs donc le soir où sa mère me
contacter je vois des affaires qui ne
sont pas à moi à ce moment là j'ai tout
jean corps en les échangeant jeudi à sa
mère je vous rapporte tout où je vais de
moi même au commissaire si vous préférez
je suis allée au commissariat déposer
toutes les affaires sans même avoir de
convocation c'est aussi pour ça que
sasha s'est énervé parce que la police
m'a dit ben on va peut-être pas écrire
au procureur vu que vous avez été de
bonne foi dès le départ donc voila moi
je démens ce que dit sacha est
d'ailleurs sacha est venu me voir cette
semaine il a dormi chez moi toute la
semaine j'ai des enregistrements vocaux
et des enregistrements vidéo de lui et
c'est pour ça qu'il a eu peur où il me
dit je sais très bien que tu ne m'as pas
volé j'ai aussi des enregistrements
vocaux qui m'a envoyé ce via whatsapp où
il me dit qu'il sait que je suis escorte
depuis le départ et que c'est ça qu'il
l'a énervé en vous parce que vous l'avez
dit tout de suite que cette escort ou
pas non ça c'est l'erreur que j'ai fait
je lui ai menti et quand il parle de
conques tout le monde parle bien sûr je
vis un moment non je lui ai dit à la fin
en fait déjà médias bon voilà c'est ça
et quand tout le monde parle de mensonge
c'est vrai je suis escorte gelé et et
j'avais beaucoup d'argent liquide
je sais pas si vous connaissez un peu
les fourchettes de prix j'ai
complètement arrêté
c'est vrai que j'ai une bonne can 2012
ça c'est derrière moi
temps ford escort mais bon et donc oui
et donc c'est quoi les anges verts en
fait quand on me demande à moi je vise
et sachant que oui c'est vrai je faisais
rien c'est qu'on les force à des prix
plus je connais pas dire ça
c'est des mille la chance d'avoir deux
mois le mois passé
ces six là passez à la tuque au nez un
peu quand même
tu veux dire et je ne mange pas de ce
pain là j'ai la chance d'avoir un
physique avantageux
pas le physique mais j'ai pas des mille
balles par van persie calme-toi kavanagh
non mais yasmine quoi s'est mise balle
1000 euros par plus des fois c'est ça
pour aller manger un resto défense et
c'est vrai j'ai changé ouais c'est vrai
mais oui c'est vrai je peux aller au
resto avec une opel ça n'aurait qu'une
belle cécile ils auront exactement ouais
voilà donc quand on me posait des
questions art on parle de mensonge d'où
te vient cet argent forcément j'avais
pas envie de dire que j'étais escorte à
rue du coup je disais c'est ma famille
je n'ai pas inventé je ne les ai pas
inventés que votre père était décédé mon
père oui mon père mon père de petit mon
père biologique ne l'est pas d'accord
parce qu est ce qui me dit voilà il
voit là vous l'avez inventé une famille
et vous avez inventé cette famille en
fait ça pour démonter cette fois où je
lui ai dit que l'argent vient de ma
famille oui ça c'est vrai alors vous
inventez vous avez inventé une vie quand
même où vivait largement au dessus de
vos moyens mais en fait vous l'avez dit
c'est parce que vous gagnez extrêmement
bien votre vie
juste ce que vous avez volé des
personnes ou pas oui vous ne l'avez pas
poli mais je vais en venir là d'accord
en fait du coup le poste de sa chasse
que ce que ça a fait c'est juste une
énorme médiatisation ça a explosé en
fait ça c'est vrai quand j'étais plus
jeune donc moi je viens d'une famille
très modeste en mon éducation n'a pas
été très limité c'est à dire que en
j'avais les mauvaises fréquentations
j'étais vu dans ma petite ville comme
une petite délinquante on aller par
exemple à intermarché ont volé des
bouteilles des fois on a poussé à un
personnel de la sécurité etc donc oui
oui j'ai volé des personnes à cette
période là c'est pour ça qu'ils parlent
de deux procès-verbaux et d'attac contre
moi d'il ya 4 5 ans en fait et c'est
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que d'accord
avec des personnes mais à ce moment là
en fait je n'avais pas de limites
j'avais pas de revenus et c'était il ya
super longtemps et c'est réagissent mais
en fait qu'on a réagi au poste de sacha
parce que forcément comme moi je postais
aussi les gens de chez moi de cognac
voyez en fait ces postes et donc on
réagit et à cognac et j'étais connues
comme g j'étais jeune comme une petite
délinquance alors reste c'est totalement
faux semis ne vous allez continuer à
dire ce que vous dites mais apparemment
les équipes me disent que sacha veut
revenir à voir cette passion avec votre
travail la sala c'est ce qu'on attend
donc mieux il va revenir dans un instant
voudrais terminer l'histoire avec vous
l'a dit vous avez vu ça chez vous lui
auriez avoué les vols les arnaques ces
fausses annonces assez faux je me suis
moqué lui en lui disant j'ai un
ordinateur dont ça s'est déformée je le
disais un ordinateur où j'ai piraté son
téléphone portable mais c'était pour
rire j'ai encore les échanges sur mon
téléphone je lui ai dit non j'ai pas
piraté son téléphone
voilà il est venu et puis toute la
semaine il m'a dit ah mais vient on
déforme un petit peu comme ça on cherche
le buzz parce que sacha a quand même
gagné douze mille fois lower en une
semaine il en est fier et j'ai des
enregistrements vocaux et vidéo de lui
où il me dit ah mais je m'en fous des
autres victimes moi tous c'était une
vengeance personnelle par rapport à
l'escorting et il me le dit encore j'ai
tout sur mon téléphone et j'ai hâte le
stresser avec moi que c'est pourquoi il
ya autant de témoignages contre vous si
vous êtes complètement innocente parce
qu'en fait c'est surtout les gens de
cognac qui ont réagi et il y a cinq
personnes que j'ai effectivement volé
donc j'ai pris en photo leurs cartes
bancaires et j'ai effectué des
transactions avec mais j'insiste sur
sarre les plis c'était à hauteur de 200
euros et y en avait cinq maximum train
quand j'ai entendu ça et j'en suis
désolé envers ces victimes là bien sûr
mais bon j'ai eu mon passé mon passé de
délinquante mon passé de mercer deux
jours en bourse a maintenant vous gagnez
bien votre vie alors mais j'ai écrit au
tout départ avant même cette
médiatisation une lettre aux procureurs
disent et à vous et j'ai même contacté
les victimes en leur disant ramener vos
relevés bancaires comme ça au moins
cette affaire sera close j'ai tout fait
en sorte que ce soit bien fait et que
maintenant tout ça soit derrière moi il
ya plein de témoignages contre vous qui
se multiplient d'anciens amis petits
copains connaissance qui vous décrite
comme une immense arnaqueuse voilà
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez la
plupart d'ailleurs la plupart je ne les
connais pas et d'ailleurs j'ai été
choquée en lisant le parisien parce que
j'ai été en contact avec le journaliste
et il n'y a pas un seul témoignage vrai
alors que moi je leur avais donné les
noms des cinq personnes que j'avais
effectivement volé je leur ai même donné
des noms de personnes quand j'étais au
collège bon je dormais chez une copine
et je piquais des vêtements etc mais ça
c'était vraiment dans mon adolescence et
un petit peu havrais après mais las de
voir des témoignages c'est fort quand
même c'est choquant ça parle de milliers
d'euros ça parle de chantage ou j'ai dit
à un certain mais qu'ils étaient
homosexuels apparemment oui si tu me
donnes pas 7000 euros eh ben je dis à
tes parents mais tout ça c'est fois
c'est incroyable que c'est faux ça c'est
incroyable je trouve ça incroyable des
photos compromettantes ces fonds je ne
sais pas mais je sais pas si c'est de
sasha mais sincèrement je ne l'emmènerai
sa maman quand vous avez comme comme ça
fait vraiment envoyer des photos
compromettantes oui et ça par contre
n'ont pas de menace mais en fait j'ai
été tellement ces points sur fautes au
sol et des photos ou sachets se drogue
parce que c'est ça le gros problème
c'est ça c'est j'en avais juste marre
j'en avais marre d'accord donc vous avez
envoyé des photos à sa maman oui c'est
ça c'est sûr dernière l'énervement et je
pense que c'est pour ça aussi qu'il a il
le dit lui-même mais sincèrement je ne
m'amuserais pas et je n'irai pas sur ce
terrain glissant tout ce que dit le
parisien je trouve ça choquant quand vos
comptes y entend des photos nues quand
ils se droguent pas non c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi qui ai pris des photos
sans bet ils ont un groupe sur instagram
avec tous ses amis ils s'envoient c'est
tout ce temps ils prennent tous voilà
ils s'envoient pour s'amuser et moi je
je faisais partie de ce groupe là vu que
j'étais en couple avec sacha est en fait
moi quand j'ai quitté sacha je me suis
dit bon là si jamais il commence parce
que sacha il fait peur quand il est
énervé si jamais ils commencent à faire
quelque chose ou qui vient chez moi
parce qu'il avait qu'ils avaient
l'adresse j'enverrai c'est à sa mère
parce que enfin je trouve ça incroyable
quand même qu'il cache tout ça et qu il
me remet alors voilà justement ça ça
revient ça sert à revenir sacha il faut
avoir une discussion avec vous sur le
plateau et merci fait montre et sasha
jeter auprès souper s'il vous plaît
faites rentrer et sasha hockey de retour
on veut qu'on veut installer sa shia
sacha et le ciel juste derrière à plus
par bercy et à la basse et les toilettes
[Rires]
sas a eu quand vous avez entendu tout ce
qu'a dit yasmine qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de vous dire ce soir alors je
tiens juste à dire que s'il ya une
enquête sur le parisien et d'autres
médias qui sont moi c'est très au
sérieux c'est que ce ne sont pas
simplement des témoignages qui a
beaucoup de prix mais je vais mal ne
vient pas sur ce terrain glissant si
c'était faux tout le monde la france
entière en train de me voir je me fiche
c'est faux tous les témoignages et il
s'était toutefois cette semaine que de
france je t'ai dit que c'était faux
j'étais même dit insiste sur ça parce
que le truc de l'homosexuel c'est faux
je ne m'aventurerais tu sais que je suis
je suis pas bête sacha c'est faux tout
ça je ne nierai pas attaquer le parisien
alors à sa charrette là je voudrais que
et sont le droit de réponse de sacha
alors centre est quand même très bizarre
qu'ils aient toutes ses touches toutes
ces enquêtes là beaucoup de preuves
beaucoup de dépôts de plaintes beaucoup
des monnaies bout d'un moment je suis
d'accord je te tiens ou de déménagements
ou des gens veulent peut-être surfer sur
la vague j'en sais rien oui mais en tout
cas évidemment quand à 100 témoignages
quant à des dépôts de plainte quand tu
as des preuves des photos des relevés de
comptes bancaires au bout d'un moment
c'est très facile nous avait parlé de
stupéfiants oui en fait c'est vrai c'est
sa vie c'est ça les photos alors pour le
coup yasmine c'est que je suis en
comment diriger mon jugement bientôt à
l'attention des tensions type de
situation dépendra en revanche alors pas
du tout en revanche ce qu'elle essaie de
faire c'est de détourner l'attention sur
le sujet principal qui sont les
escroqueries en parlant justement de de
drogue de jean sérien de tout le monde
finalement peut-être s'en fiche jeu mais
bon les escroqueries vous pour vous
confirmer que yasmina escroquerie un oui
bien sûr bien sûr et d'ailleurs je les
possède une vidéo sur ce mot instagram
en disant que que clairement voilà je
pense que nous d'eux quand je voyais ont
su filmer tous les deux pour ceux piégés
donc c'est un peu bête de ma part mais
je
vous avais à dire bah c'est rien j'ai
rien à dire en fait moi quand est venue
à la maison tu m'a dit tu m'a même parlé
comment j'aurais pu savoir pour m6 sans
que tu me le dise tu sais que j'ai des
échange avec toi ou tu me dises te plaît
me tente pas de pelé vient en fait si en
fait tu as mis cette vidéo sur internet
sacha parce que tu m'a cramé le matin le
matin hier matin peu entreprenants en
vidéo tu m'a cramé et à partir de ce
moment là tu as fait cette vidéo là vous
prenez en vidéo en train de prendre des
stupéfiants c'est ça non non non le
prénom vidéo que les deux corps à corps
les deux il m'a même dit j'ai pris douze
mille fois le web en une semaine c'est
trop bien enfin c'est pas du feu prévenu
alors je tiens à dire si vous voulez
prouver ma bonne foi que si cette fille
est condamné et jugé je supprimerai tous
mes réseaux sociaux d'accord
je ne peux pas être condamné pour le
moment c'est vraiment de yasmine c'est
vrai que là vous avez un argumentaire
très structuré
ne dis pas que c'est faux le dixel très
convaincant comment vous expliquer le
décalage avec la yasmine décrite quand
même par le parisien ne fait pas
n'importe quoi décrite par sacha oui
décrite par tous les témoignages
escapade de yasmine non moi vous là mais
de l'autre côté en escroc de haut vol
est bien sûr toujours sa demande je vais
elle c'est très pertinent que je vais
vous répondre en fait auparavant je vous
assure repart avant j'étais la pire
filles possible même ma mère pleurait
parce que je lui faisais toutes les
crasses possible j'ai même piquer de
l'argent à ma mère quand j'étais
adolescente c'est pas pour rien que j'ai
été en internat après je me suis mis
dans le bon cadre j'ai même été à
l'armée pour avoir une certaine
structure j'ai fait en sorte de devenir
meilleur même ma mère me dit l'avait me
dis la même chose tu as changé quand
j'étais plus jeune j'ai eu des traumas
pas possible je ne vais pas raconter ma
vie ni même faire en sorte que les gens
s'apitoie sur mon sort mais j'ai des
traumas incroyable et moi à ce moment là
en fait j'étais totalement perdu absence
de père même ma mère excusez moi mais
elle est en dépression depuis des années
moi je faisais n'importe quoi jubiler
mais buzz fréquentation et j'ai fait en
sorte en fait quand j'ai vu cette
publication tout ça de contacter moi
même l'été les victimes et j'ai encore
des messages en fait c'est juste que
sacha a plus d'audience que moi et à
l'heure actuelle avant avant aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas pu dans le parisien il se
fit pas alors
que je veux dire
quand je serai pas là dessus si c'est
faux je vais me taper la honte de ma vie
je vous promets
vous êtes vraiment tombée amoureuse de
lui mais un but et je suis toujours
amoureuse de lui mais bien sûr que oui
c'est beaucoup trop récent en fait et
moi quand j'ai mon petit frère qui m'a
brûlée qui me dit parce qu'il est en
vacances il me dit j'ai peur d'aller à
l'école parce que je vais me faire il ya
déjà des amis en fait à moi qui se moque
de moi c'est horrible c'est affreux
cette diffamation dans les arrêts de jeu
mais non j'ai arrêté mais tout ça danse
ça jouera à mons 2 mais bien sûr que oui
mais c est ça et vous et vous
franchement j'ai pas vraiment envie que
ça recommence à l'arrêté je vais
vraiment
mais parce que c'est vrai que voilà mon
amour
on attend un peu sincère et la
présence dimanche pensez forcément j'ai
jamais douté je peux vous faire écouter
un message vocal ou sacha dit
bruce achats dits oui je sais que tu es
escorte depuis le départ c'est pas du
tout ce qu'il a dit de tout à l'heure il
le sait apparemment depuis le début et
c'est ce qui l'a énervé parce que je lui
ai menti ça c'est vrai c'est ce qui l'a
énervé et il monte un plan contre moi
depuis les bars c'est ce qu'il a dit
dans le message je les fais écouter à la
régie alors
pourquoi je ne peux pas montré ses
preuves là en fait là je suis victime de
tout ça alors que je le mérite pas je
n'ai aucune j'ai fait des erreurs quand
j'étais plus jeune mais à l'heure
actuelle sincèrement je me suis fait
tellement d'argent avec l'escorting que
je club il il avait sorti andy les
scorpions sont les méthodes
lesquelles personne envoie sa merde et
des photos que ces mails et messages
partagés tout ça c'était pas c'était pas
du chantage c'est juste c'est dit et
regardez votre drogué deux fils j'ai
pété un câble parce qu'on venait juste
de se quitter parce qu'il m'a insulté
comme pas possible c'était de l'amour
quand on ressent de l'amour et qui est
il m'insultait comme ça qu'il me traite
de plus devant tout le monde killer
j'étais énervé j'étais juste énervé
comment est ce que vous expliquez donc
la disparition des objets convient
challandes hilare mais expliqué
explique-moi sacha expliquer à tout le
monde pourquoi tu n'as pas voulu que je
fasse mes affaires à la chaleur maladie
elle a dit ça leur rappelle rarement
formant ce
kabyle des affaires qui n'était pas elle
a chassé quoi qu'il appartiendrait alors
je peux dire quelque chose bien sûr
témoin en fait qui était son un de ses
meilleurs amis du coup il m'a dit qu'au
préalable dans la semaine donc c'était
pas du cno sur le moment qu'elle avait
volé mais dirhams calé au bureau de
change mais où les épreuves de glace moi
je les ai toutes ces tombes c'est ton
meilleur ami finalement il ya la photo
mais rami hausse on sait que j'avais
touché l'unam anciens clients où sont
ses preuves pourquoi tu les affiche pas
tu as tellement d'audience sur instagram
pourquoi tu n'as fait chaud que tu as
voulu me piéger apparemment ces deux
semaines sacha on est d'accord qu'en mai
où sont les vues pas bien sûr vos
méthodes ce qu'on me disait mathieu
elles sont comme wesley so col missionné
déjà du chantage non mais faut toi sa
maman vous allez voir sa meilleure amie
pour lui dire si c'est vrai cette
histoire de vous arrêter voire sa
meilleure amie pour voir si elle pouvait
faire des scores possibles en page
estime j'ai juste proposé à cette fille
là je lui ai dit je vais un match de
basket c'est un mec qui m'a contacté il
est super riches il m'a donné de plage
tu peux venir avec moi c'est encore plus
fort quand même oui mais non c'était
sympa l'escorting ne l'est pas je les
rencontre en floride il ya des matches
de basket avec un gazier avec moi il est
hyper riches ne connaît pas on est
encore un petit peu je me suis tu va
ressortir avec des sacs de jute et non
en fait c'est vraiment pas sur le
sporting je te veux même pas y être
surtout sur les volumes
s'est passé ok ça c'est des petites
vengeances personnelles sur la scor
parce que tu m'as trahi maintenant le
reste c'est des histoires d'escroquerie
elle dit que c'était il ya quatre ans
que c'était suite à son passé et cgt
témoignages l'épreuve même de jean
pierre laquet appareil a pas longtemps
haifa date de trois ou quatre mois cinq
mois j'ai beaucoup de gens qui sont fait
pas le bonheur carte bleue ou tu vous
allez voir dans son cloud ya énormément
de quatre bleus elle m'avait expliqué
elle m'a quand même expliquer comment
elle faisait parce que à l'époque
fallait passer par paypal parce que
sinon ça passait par le 3d secure igier
qui sont la lettre au procureur n'est
pas le talent est toujours escort
annonce a arrêté ce jour là à la fin je
travaillais en fait je travaillais pour
la brp voilà et j'allais dans certaines
soirées j'ai aussi l'épreuve et je
prouverai vol à vue à la brigade de
répression contre le proxénétisme
il me demandait d'aller dans certaines
soirées et puis de leur dire si c'était
des proxénètes ou pas et si les échanges
j'ai encore l'épreuve mémoire du compte
combien vaut le thème les bijoux de son
père ana c avec mais non mais ça c'est
fort
les a rendus devant le pgi hadders
maison devant l'autre parce que je les
ai retrouvé dans les sacs que tu m'as
fait sascha d'accord j'ai les messages
et les messages mais non j'ai ma liberté
les sacs et d'amis des trucs dessus
a dit qu'il ya quand je les pieds
effectivement préparer des sacs je lui
ai dit vas-y je te donne les sacs elle a
dit non c'est moi qui viens les prendre
elle est venue chez moi elle est
repartie avec est en fait déjà j'ai des
témoignages donc de ton pote je veux pas
dire son nom chekib at-on anciens
clients du coup il me dit que
effectivement je serais revenu donc le
mercredi avec beaucoup avec beaucoup de
bijoux non la leur c'est mon père
accident j'aurais mis là nuances de tons
verts eelv et mon père dans tout ça
qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'on avait volé
mes affaires et certes quand ta mère
n'était pas là tu sais que j'avais
emprunté des affaires a atteint cousine
que tu as retrouvé d'ailleurs mais bon
les bijoux en fait c'est vrai j'avais
portait une bague et j'avais porté un
truc mais je les avais tous remis dans
la salle de bain c'est pour ça que ta
mère les a retrouvés alessio gasmi votre
histoire c'est un film de netflix la
série dont vous venez de nous dire en
plus de tous vous venez de nous dire que
finalement à la fin vous étiez indic de
la police non mais sérieux et si vous
voulez dire ça me travaillait pour la
brigade de mémoire me concernant non
mais pourquoi je mentirais non mais
alors ils vous ont alors à ses yeux qui
vous ont protégé s'immunise un stratège
on est content parce que ils m'ont dit
ça c'est pas vrai on va le savoir des
gg les échanges vous étiez un indic de
la police mais j'ai je l'étais oui c'est
vrai vous voulez voir les échanges vous
voulez voir les mines en
chine ont été remontés
s'il vous plaît est ce que vous auriez à
dire à sacha ce soir en 10 secondes la
sq est ce que vous auriez dû dire à
sacha oui mais qu'il soit il faut qu'il
arrête parce que aller jusqu'aux
parisien et voir tout ça mais en fait
c'est carrément toute ma famille qui se
fait harceler c'est tout le monde mais
moi en fait je suis victime de tout ça
alors que j'ai écrits de moi-même sacha
depuis le départ sur ça que j'étais
invité chez moi pour te donner cette
lettre la copie de cette lettre j'ai
assumé tous les vols que j'avais fait
lorsque j'étais plus jeune c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu en fait autant de réponses
sur tombe à tous autres non merci que ce
qu'elle devrait lui dire sacha au fini
moi ça veut dire que certes son frère sa
famille qui se fait harceler c'est pas
du tout ce que je voulais
sechin et oui c'est vrai sur le nez vers
malawi bien cher moi aussi d'ailleurs je
manque la romieu mais c'est dexter est
ok c'est vrai j'étais c'était le soir où
vraiment j'ai vu qu'elle avait tous
volés dont les baggies
ok certes j'ai dit des choses
franchement beaucoup je veux dire que
mon comme j'ai dit à leurs mon combat il
est sain après j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses où j'ai laissé parler trop mes
émotions parce que effectivement je me
venait de me faire voler avec star et
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure en fait à
chaleur je suis vraiment de qualité
indique ou pas je te le disais et je te
les ai envoyé les messages elle m'avait
dit qu'elle était un dimitri j'en ai
parlé avec son pote qui m'a dit non je
fais juste draguer par des policiers